[Music]
alright guys welcome to our Sunday
advanced kids class my name is vitaly
namer and I'm the Grand Master resident
here at the Chess Club and today we are
going to have a fun class usually we
discuss some openings or some end games
I show you some games today it's gonna
be all about fun and what's more fun
than discussing openings which are
called by animal names ok we have so
many openings which are called by animal
names actually by my count we have more
than 20 openings which are called by
animal names some openings are also
called by either by countries or
according to the last name of the player
who invented those those openings today
it's going to be the first part of our
serious openings with animal names
downtown so today we are going to cover
about 10 to 12 openings and we will see
if you can cover most of them today some
of you know of those openings some of
you might it might be something new to
you some of those openings are good to
play they might be very sound to play
and but some of them might be not so
good so don't take it as an advice to
play them just because their name sounds
very cool
ok you guys ready alrighty so if you
guys ready and now viewers ready let's
go to our first opening this is the
opening that I already covered in my
previous lectures and this is the four
nights opening sometimes we have we call
them the nights sometimes we call them
horses but one of the most famous chess
openings is the full night's opening
efore a59 of 396 93 96 that's the
beginning of the full night's opening
okay so as you can see everybody is
controlling the center with one of the
pawns everybody developed one of the
knights and this is why it's called the
four Knights opening usually the game
continues white is playing Bishop to b5
black and continue Bishop to b4 white
castles here and black castles okay so
this is what we call the full night's
opening one of the most popular openings
we have on the chessboard
in the chess game very easy to remember
because as you can see we have four
Knights on the board okay so far so good
so this was the first opening the four
Knights opening now let's go to our next
not opening number two opening number
two is going to be the Sicilian Hedgehog
there is a chess opening which is called
the Hedgehog some people call it
Scheveningen but as some people like to
call it the Hedgehog white start was
efore and I'm gonna flip the board
because this is an opening which is
chosen by black c5
Knight f3 d6 d4 pawn takes on d4 Knight
takes on d4 Knight to f6 coming here to
attack this pawn on e4 Knight to c3 this
is pretty much one of the most popular
and open positions we have in the
Sicilian he'll black can choose between
many many openings so the first one word
that we are going to cover today is the
Hedgehog and in this position black
plays this move pawn to e6 so why is
this is this opening called the Hedgehog
let's see if anybody here it our
audience today you can figure this out
why is it called the hedgehog well the
previous one was called the full Knights
because we developed the four Knights
but why is it called the Hedgehog why is
it called the Hedgehog yes please
exactly the d6 pawn and the e6 pawn they
are acting as the spikes if you know the
Hedgehog when when he is being
threatened and he when he is afraid he
occurs into a ball of spikes and no
other animal can touch it it's a it's a
defensive mechanism okay
so the same way and this in this opening
we have the Hedgehog opening it's kind
of a structure of those two pawns those
spikes defend black from all enemies who
who might be coming at black now usually
black wants to then develop his one of
his knights so that's in 96 then he's
going to develop both of his bishops and
he can castle
short as you can see this is a very
defensive opening some people like to
defend for example as you can see here
blacks pieces are all across only the
sixth rank so they are very very
different defended on the other hand
White's pieces are already in the center
so white is the one who gets more
control in the center so this is why we
call it the sicilian hedgehog alright
let's go to our next next position next
opening opening number three and this is
going to be also coming out of the
Sicilian but this one is the one the
most with the most cool names possible
and this is the Sicilian dragon alright
I see that some people play it here and
the audience very exciting opening so
let's see how can we become the dragon
efore c5 Knight to f3 d6 we have by the
way a few variations of the dragon we
have the regular dragon we also have
something that we call accelerated
dragon just fast so dragon obviously we
want to be maybe a facile dragon but
today I'm just going to show you just
the main dragon d6 pawn to d4 we go
exactly to the same position as we
discussed in the Hedgehog 9 takes on d4
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and now we can
either chose a6 as we've seen it can
become we can play the Hedgehog or you
can play this move pawn to g6 and this
is what we call the Sicilian dragon
technically this move is what we call a
fear and shadow in chess we are building
a small house for
the bishop okay so g6 and I'm going to
show you just one of the variations that
are usually played by white white
against dragon likes to castle longer he
decides to make opposite side
casting game which is much much more
sharp Bishop to e3 is being played
Bishop to g7 f3 black castles Queen d2
96 Bishop c4 Bishop d7 long castle and
black is playing rook to c2 c8 now let's
see in our audience who can figure this
out why do we call it the dragon why is
this is this structure for black is
called the dragon let's see who knows
let's see who knows what is the reason
why do we call it the dragon yes please
very good so one answer that people
usually know is that the the Bishop on
g7 defend chattel bishop acts as a fire
he is the fire he's very very strong
bishop and he usually the one that is
most dangerous in this opening and then
the a and the B pawn because we know the
opposite side casting they are the tail
and the tail of the dragon is not worse
than the fire littell is also very
dangerous if if somebody hits by the
dragon's tail so this is why black will
try to push his pawns and mate the King
on c1 so this is the most common reason
why we call it the dragon but who knows
the real reason why we call it the
direct the dragon what's the real one
there is actually a real one was the
real reason yes please
hmm because you're almost always
attacking like a dragon the dragon never
defense that's a good answer but not the
real answer what is the real answer yes
please the shape of the pawns is like a
dragon do you guys see a dragon here hmm
almost almost you're very close it's
about the shape of the pawns what about
the shape of the pawns let's see anybody
else has any other ideas yes please very
good Wow
yes this is correct if anybody of you
likes astronomy in the astronomy we have
stars if when we look at space every
chain of stars we call it a
constellation and the constellation
there's a constellation which is called
Draco
which means the dragon and those pawns
that I just highlighted they are making
this it's there is the same
constellation of stars so I I encourage
everybody today at night before you go
to sleep look at the Stars and try to
find the dragon
okay the next the next opening we are
moving to opening number four opening
number four for today
efore a five it starts just as a 4/9
defense with Knight to f3 Knight to c6
but now why display this move Bishop to
c4 now sometimes people call it the
Italian but it all depends on the
response of black if black plays Bishop
to c5 this is what we call the Italian
or they go eco piano pianissimo but
black has another option to play here
and this is Knight to f6 and strangely
enough this opening we call the two
knights
opening the two knights opening although
we have three nights so sometimes pea
like to refer to as a three nights
opening but he but theoretically we call
it the two nights opening which is a
pretty good opening pretty good opening
for black and for white to play so the
two nights opening now let's move to the
next one let's move to the next of the
next opening starts with a move d4
that's the other move this is very
popular among top chess players
efore and d4 are the most popular chess
moves to begin with the next opening
that I'm going to show you don't be
scared I know that you public scared of
all of this opening but it is called the
snake Benoni
it's called the snake Shh
I don't know if anybody here like snakes
but I don't I don't I'm afraid of snakes
Shh so let's see how do we play this
snake banani 9 12 6 the system is used
by Black Knight of 6 now C 4 and C 5
this is the beginning of the bonanni
opening and the variation is the snake
d5 white does not take the pawn on c5
white prefers to get more space a 693
pawn takes on d5 pawn takes on d5 and
now the usual move is g6 just like in
the dragon black wants to fetch a 2 is
bishop however let's black bow fails to
be a snake the style not a dragon and in
the snake we play Bishop to d6 Knight of
3 black castles so black castles first
that's only a good sign for black Bishop
to g5 we get we're getting pinned but
that's ok because right now we can just
the
I'll rock rook to e8 rook to e8 III and
one of the last moves is Bishop to c7 so
who knows why do we call it the snake
the snake bonanni why do we call it the
snake let's see who in the audience can
figure this out why do we call it the
snake yes please
so you're saying the snake is like it's
it's like hiding usually and then
suddenly attacks from the shadows and
you're saying that black is kind of
hiding still but then is money might
capture is praying okay good idea
not exactly it's close its close yes
it's trying to defend itself like a
snake okay maybe yes very good it is
about the bishop again look at this
bishop which was on f8 the bishop went
to d6 c7 and then the bishop the idea is
to bring the Bishop to a5 and attack the
king from this diagonal so instead of
fearing chanting the bishop like a
dragon we like to move the bishop like a
snake exactly stiller's so this is the
snake Benoni
okay next one I think we're at opening
number 506 at six
now the next one are going to be more
over less advanced openings white does
play d4 black sacrifices respond with E
5 what is that well obviously we're
going to take the pawn it starts as an
unguent yes very good there is such an
opening but now black plays this stage
move Queen h4
and this this variation is called the
mosquito gamble there mosquito Gammons
the mosquito gambit because we sacrifice
upon and the Queen acts as a mosquito
she can go here she can go she attacks
here
she basically lots and lots of options
for black day mosquito gambit anybody
likes mosquitos here no no we don't like
mosquitoes already now the next one is
much much more different than the
mosquito gambit this opening is played
by white white starts with E 4 E 5 and
now white makes this strange move Bishop
to d3
hmm anybody knows what's the name of
this opening anybody knows it's a very
I'm gonna give you a hint it's a very
slow developing move it's one of the
slowest animals will we ever have here
one of the slowest ones however though
there was and they there wasn't a movie
about this animal it's kind of like a
series those animals they know how to
ninja ninja fight whilst the world is
yes please that turtle it's called the
tour toys opening it's very slow slow
development by white very good now the
next opening is played by black on e4
black plays g6
d for Bishop to g7 Knight f3 and now
black panchito's his other Bishop B 693
and Bishop e7 some people in the
audience say is the mother it is not the
mother this opening this opening is
called the hippopotamus opening or the
hippo the hippo now let's look what
let's look what else do we do Bishop c4
e6 Bishop to f4 d6 Castle 97 rookie 1
and Knight to d7 now although although
it looks like a very bad opening for
black because I don't have the center
right I don't I did not put one of my
pawns in the center this opening the
hippo was played by one of the world
champions Boris Spassky so if there were
if the if a world champion played a
hippo it's not so bad because the idea
of the hippo is why anybody knows why is
it called the hippo what is so strong
about the hippo anybody knows anybody
watches not National Geographic over
here what is so dangerous about the
hippos they look like nice animals but
there's a secret to them what's the
secret of the hippos yes Adi
yeah so the hippos do run very fast and
me why play see 500 f5 but you're going
to expose yourself anybody else any
other idea why is it called the hippo
yes it bites hard now look at this
anybody else anybody any other ideas yes
because blacks position looks very fat
okay I I'm going to be insulted on the
hippos behalf okay we were just
big-sized okay we're not fat thank you
very much now it is called the hippo
because the danger of the hippos is that
they lie under water look at this pawn
structure this is our water we lie under
water and when somebody comes to drink
the water they come out and jump so then
the idea for black is actually to attack
on the flanks with the pawns it's a very
very dangerous it invites its prey with
E 5 and then we attack D 5 if white
tries to push D 5 we will play e5 so
don't underestimate the hippo very
dangerous animal very very dangerous
opening ok the neck the next one the
next opening is also played by black D 4
is 6 C 4 Bishop before check the bishop
jumps to before the name of this opening
is who wants to guess what's the name of
this opening somebody I'm going to give
you a hint
a jumping animal who jumps a big animal
that not a small one
ok raise your hand yes
kangaroo this is the kangaroo defense
also called the
Cara's defense very good very good now
we have three more openings this opening
is also this opening is played by by
white look at the first move that's
white that white white makes and this
opening night to h3o what a bad move
what a bad move Knight h3 and this
opening has Shh this opening has a lots
and lots of names first of all we know
that we don't want to put our Knights on
the edge of the board however this is
called as the Parrish opening it's also
called as the drunken night opening also
it is called it is also called the crazy
cat opening and it is also called the
ammonia opening anybody knows what
ammonia is anybody likes chemistry here
anybody knows yes so what is what how do
you define ammonia what is the
definition you know every chemical has
has its own name who knows was the name
of ammonia in there in chemistry
so each chemical has its own name the
cat the name of ammonia is nh3 Knight to
h3 so this is called the ammonia opening
okay let's look at the next one the next
one is being played by black efore g6 it
starts like a hippo but it's definitely
not going to be a hippo 92-86 and now a6
this opening is called it's called the
tiger
the Tigers model it's like a tiger now
why why was it called the tiger because
there was a very strong player tiger
Hillier who invented this this opening
so actually his name was Tiger pretty
interesting and the next one is played
by white white starts again white starts
again with a very strange move f3
this is one of the most porous moves
that we have in the chest opening after
E 5 white makes this horrible move came
to have to this opening has a few
attacks a few names one of them it is
called the wandering king the King
wonders doesn't does not have a castle
also it is called sometimes the half
bird at opening also it is called the
fried Fox attack or the pork chop the
pork chop opening last but at least we
don't have time today to discuss the
opening today
but there's another opening which I
invented and I call it the Hydra anybody
heard about the mythological creature
the Hydra anybody knows about that
creature you know about the creature
[Music]
[Music]
Wow so many details it was it was a
creature with many heads and if you
would cut off one of his heads another
one will grow up and yes very good it's
almost you give so many details it
almost sounds like you were fighting
against the Hydra only thing I can tell
about the Hydra is it is played by white
and white starts with a move d4 that's
the only move I can tell you today we
don't have enough time but we will
continue all of our other openings in
part 2 stay tuned for the animal
openings next week
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]